es ist wirklich eine absolute sensation
seit gestern hat ein neues zeitalter der
astronomie begonnen denn gestern ging es
um die welt am 17 august fand ein ganz
besonderes ereignis im universum stand
und zum aller ersten mal konnte es
parallel mit dem fermi satelliten und
dem gravitationswellen detektor lego in
den usa beobachtet werden die kollision
zweier neutronensterne konnte so auf nie
dagewesene art und weise analysiert
werden warum das alles ändert in der
astronomie jetzt den klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
es war der erste beitrag hier bei pixum
science fiction es ging um den stärksten
gamma ray burst den stärksten gamma
blitz aller zeiten
er traf die erde am 27 april 2013 gott
sei dank war die quelle 3,6 milliarden
lichtjahre entfernt er war aber so stark
dass er den messbereich der satelliten
fermi der gamma ray burst untersucht
überschritten hat trotzdem konnte er der
erde nichts anhaben er war viel zu weit
entfernt das war wohl nicht immer so die
astrophysik vermutet hinter einem gamma
blitz den grund für ein massensterben
vor 443 millionen jahren auf der erde
und jetzt wurde wieder ein ganz
besonderer gamma ray burst beobachtet er
war nicht so stark wie der gamma blitz
2013 und auch wieder weit entfernt aber
zum ersten mal wurde er nicht nur von
ferne beobachtet und gemessen sondern
auch von gravitationswellen direkt in
den usa am 17 august 2017 um 14 uhr 41
minuten und vier sekunden
mitteleuropäischer sommerzeit
detektierten beide auf ganz
unterschiedliche art und weise das
gleiche ereignis wobei ist ein minimal
zeitversatz von zwei sekunden gab der
noch erforscht werden muss zwei nummern
hat dieses ereignis deshalb zum einen
die grb 17 und 8 17
wobei ihr grb für gamma ray burst steht
also der gamma wellen ausbruch und gw
1717 wobei gebe hierfür gravitation wave
also gravitationswellen steht und diese
fast gleichzeitige messung ist etwas
ganz besonderes und ändert alles
erstmals sind es gravitationswellen die
nicht von der kollision zweier schwarzer
löcher stammen wo also nicht zu sehen
ist damit bietet sich nämlich die
möglichkeit dieses ereignis auch noch
anders zu beobachten weil es eben etwas
zu sehen gibt nämlich dessen
elektromagnetische strahlung das heißt
gammastrahlung in ultraviolette
strahlung licht infrarote strahlung und
radiowellen
damit gibt es daten die so bisher nicht
vorlage und bereits die erste
bahnbrechende erkenntnis zitat dies ist
der erste eindeutige nachweis einer
verschmelzung zweier neutronensterne
das sagt delfzijl erforscht beim
national radio astronomy operator in den
usa und werkhallen vom california
institute of technology erklärt die
geschichte die wir hier beobachten ist
damit vollständiger als jedes andere
ereignisse in der astronomie geschichte
mit den informationen die sowohl die
gravitationswellen als auch die
elektromagnetische strahlung liefern
können wir dasselbe ereignis erstmals
sowohl hören als auch see und das ist
das wirklich umwerfende kurz nachdem das
signal von neigung gefunden wurde wurde
die nachricht an zahlreiche teleskope
und forschungseinrichtungen
weitergeleitet die richteten ihre
teleskope weltweit in richtung des
ursprungs der gravitationswellen aus
nach elf stunden wurde das teleskop in
chile fündig wir sahen eine helle
bläuliche lichtquelle in einer
nahegelegenen galaxie so josh samen von
der carnegie institution war
insgesamt waren es dann 70 observatorien
inklusive dem hubble-weltraumteleskop
die das nachglühen in den verschiedenen
wellen bereichen tage lang beobachtet
haben
es wird wirklich spannend wenn es dann
noch ab nächstem jahr das riesige james
webb weltraumteleskop auf solche
ereignisse gerichtet werden kann
dann wird es voraussichtlich
unglaubliche bilder und neue
erkenntnisse gehen mega spannend wenn
ihr kein video zum thema und auch zu
allen anderen themen verpassen wollt
dann wird mehr ein abo aufs auge und
vergesst nicht den genau auf die glocke
hier geht es weiter mit dem video zum
stärksten blitz aller zeiten wird ein
gamma blitz die erde zerstört der
hellste blitz aller zeiten
das erste video von klicks und science
fiction schon witzig wie alles begann
also ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran